hey everybody and welcome to wild ride
with stevo
oh boy is there a lot of crazy stuff
happening these days
and you're gonna find out about all of
it very soon
but now how about this we got more than
a legend of gangster rap on this week's
episode
and if you thought my voice was iconic
or controversial oh man
this guy is awesome so
with great honor let me say
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
the doc
yeah dude
hey man i want you to meet my co-host
scott randolph
what's up doc my pleasure scott nice to
meet you what should i call you doc or
by your name it doesn't matter everybody
calls me doc
all right all right doc all right man
what an honor dude a true
legend of the game man i almost think
legend doesn't even do the trick
with you you know what that's that's
that's that's a blessing here you say
that bro
i'm a huge fan and we got a lot in
common
yeah we do we we've both done a lot of
crazy [ __ ]
in our lifetime you know yeah my honor
is mine man
thank you very much for that coach oh
hey brother it's uh it's a big deal man
you know i'll never forget watching a
documentary
i was god i did so much cocaine i think
i i was doing cocaine
and then i was like uh watching the
documentary until i would hit pause and
then go back to the porno and then back
to the documentary like
i needed a little time to recharge you
know yeah
and while i was recharging i was
watching uh
the documentary welcome to death row and
man
what a story that was at the end of that
documentary
everybody was pretty much dead
or in jail and there was like
hundreds of millions of dollars that had
just gone missing
yeah right and and you were uh
one of the co-founders of death row yeah
yeah yeah
yeah one of the one of the lucky or
unlucky
people depending on how you look at it
uh
but it was a hell of a [ __ ] ride i
tell you that that was
and to be honest with you i learned a
whole lot it was a blessing to go
through this [ __ ] but it was [ __ ]
crazy
i mean you were like 20 21 when that was
going down right
i was 21. i just i just had this
i just had this monster [ __ ] car
crash on the 101
and lost my voice so i was just all
[ __ ] up
really from that and i dove straight
from that
into devra yeah man i mean i know that
like every comment on all this is the
man
the two guys with the voices
[Laughter]
my my voice is uh is not too much
different from yours man i hear about it
all the time dude i made a video called
why my voice is so messed up and that's
like
the most popular video i makes everybody
wants to know like man why's your voice
sound like that uh and it turns out i
just use it bad i'm just not gonna
like i just i use it poorly yeah
yeah i think i think i'll do that [ __ ]
too
i i i heard in an interview that you
introduced suge knight with dr dre
and obviously you introduced you know
dr dre for the reasons he's a music
producer but what would what made you
think
that suge knight would be good at like
getting businesses together did he have
a background in making things happen
like that or was he just kind of like
the guy
suga and i had already been kind of
uh messing around for about a year or so
and she and i at that time had offices
in beverly
hills and i was coming from from dallas
texas
you know coming from [ __ ] kicking to
[ __ ]
beverly hills office i thought the dude
could do it all and
truth was he you know he got in the way
he got in
you know well yeah he was he was a
bodyguard for bobby brown was that right
i think he worked for bob before me
uh but he wasn't my bodyguard he just
hung out with these
fun hanging around with we got in
trouble
you know i mean and i knew what nobody
gonna kick my ass as long as this
how'd you guys meet somebody we had a
mutual friend the guy that
brought me to california was a was a
friend of his
they called each other brothers and i
met sure to that guy
and she started taking me to all the
clubs in hollywood
i'd get [ __ ] drunk as hell and slap
some woman on her butt
her boyfriend would get into a fight
[ __ ] would be the dog club and we'd get
kicked out
i did it for all year so so when nwa
popped off you were in dallas and you
came to
la after no
nwa hadn't popped off yeah
okay got it yeah when i got there
then easy ease record happened then in
the ways record happened
and and it was just a [ __ ]
show by that time yeah and it came after
that
so easy record was uh put out on
ruthless
that was before death row oh yeah oh
yeah yeah
and where did the money come from for uh
for there's the who's the silent partner
he didn't want any credit because uh
he was kind of like tied up in some
stuff so he didn't want to be the face
of the company but
he put me talking about death row death
row yeah
[ __ ] i hear you here we go that's
exactly the name i was trying to think
of
and harry did harrio ever get out of
prison
yes he did i think if i'm not mistaken
uh he got blind he got pardoned cool man
and uh and here we go now that if i
remember that
he was the money that started death row
he was he
didn't love you he didn't want any
attention he was like you guys do your
thing i'm the
and then because he didn't want any
attention and because he was a silent
partner
like suge saw it was going to be pretty
easy to just cut him out because
he wasn't he didn't even really exist
and so then they cut him out and then
maybe the
the the death row lawyer was it
david keller david kenner david kenner
like maybe just saw to it uh
to keep harry oh locked up in prison huh
so that he
that they could rip him off wow i never
thought of it like that
that's happened i mean dude said like
david david kenner
he got tupac and snoop dogg off their
murder charges he had a lot of sway in
the courtroom
yeah oh yeah oh yeah when it came to
like
like keeping the money man it makes
sense dude he i think that he uh
sought to it to keep hario locked up and
i remember thinking with period gets out
of prison
some people are gonna have to pay up
they're gonna have to pay up in some
some ways well you know it's a dirty
game
it's a filthy [ __ ] mcnasty game bro
and
you gotta watch how i watch who you deal
with but
i really can't speak to it you know
that was implied i think it was implied
in the documentary
but uh but that was a different time
that was that was certainly a different
time and uh
when uh like when it all kind of came
apart
i made sure death row continued on after
and snoop and dre
left and you know but it did it wasn't
ever the same right like
it was never the same and i know that
for dre to leave he dr dre he just had
to say hey you know what my life is more
important to me
than my interest in this company than
that you know i'm just going to walk
away from it
i'm just going to take the l i'm gonna
leave it absolutely nothing to start
over completely from scratch
yeah you're talking about one of the
greatest producers of all time
he wasn't really leaving [ __ ] because
wherever he goes
yeah that's where the money's gonna go
yeah it doesn't work without drake dre
was the key to
everything so yeah it sounds good to say
i'm going to start over with nothing
yeah i think that that's that's a fair
assessment so what would you do
what was your situation when all that
went down
i mean i i i kind of get the sense that
you went from like being the artist to
being kind of behind the scenes
on the business level right by putting
it together with
with suga andre yeah that's well that's
what i was trying to do
but when i spoke to you early about that
accident right
when i had that accident it really
[ __ ] me up
yeah i mean like and so i really
couldn't concentrate on [ __ ] i was a
dope addict i was a drug guy
and it was that's all i really gave a
[ __ ] about
is being [ __ ] up so why they would
take care of their business
i was taking care of this cocaine and
it doesn't really work out well for
business people when you're not
you know you know you're in the wrong
place but in the long run
like when you think about things right
now i got my [ __ ] head back
and i got all these opportunities in
front of me and so everything's
it's all good you know man i could have
been dead
always like you said lock the [ __ ] up
for the rest of my life and
i'm trying to learn how to play [ __ ]
bass guitar right now bro
that's great man it's so funny when you
just said uh i was a
i was a drug addict but you know we had
to probably be thinking the same thing
what was your doc
yeah right like for us we're like sober
guys you know
and in our world doc means drug of
choice
i know yeah and so sorry it was coke huh
oh yeah it was well bro back then it was
whatever
you know yeah what you want you know
what you got yeah
you're right you're in a really [ __ ]
up head space and you're trying to get
out of it
right so what was the point where it
turned around
like you said you got your head back i
believe
you know i was the one that really left
with nothing
all right after all i put put in and i
said i gotta get the [ __ ]
out of here but i went to atlanta
and [ __ ] got worse
in what sense well there's more jobs
there
more money there you know i hadn't fixed
the problem
and uh that that that took a while
longer
but i got away from the drama because
you could imagine
for a guy that's really not a thug guy
i'm really not a
street guy that was never mine you know
mo
to be sort of immersed in this world
where it feels like you're on a prison
yard
every [ __ ] day that's it was
a whole lot to go through you know i
mean and if you're not
aware it will [ __ ] crumble you which
is why a lot of that alcoholic
and drugs were there to help out back
then you know
because you get to the right level and
[ __ ] you want to [ __ ] off everybody too
[ __ ] give me a gun let's shoot them
up yeah
before nwa popped off you were in dallas
and i'm guessing that's around the time
when the ghetto boys were were
in dallas and popping off were you
messing around with the ghetto boys
together boys were from
houston okay the ghetto boys were
after oh they were that's right okay
yeah that's right man i'm a dummy
but so then when you went to atlanta
were you [ __ ] around with the outcast
oh yeah good guys i see those guys
those guys are great like human beings
and [ __ ] but they party too but not like
me
yeah but they were just good soulful
people so to be back around
[Music]
you know good people again where you're
not worried about
right but somebody's shooting somebody
else stabbing somebody in
in the [ __ ] next room and [ __ ] life
gets a little easier and you can fake
you could
you make music there was a friend of
mine in uh
in atlanta rest in peace it's a guy
named mcbree
and i just shacked up at his house we
smoked tons of [ __ ] weed and made a
lot of records
good man yeah so is that where you are
now are you in are you in atlanta are
you in dallas
i'm back in dallas now okay yeah we love
dallas
north texas where all the money is right
now guys you got to come down
everybody's going to texas [ __ ] yeah man
because
does that bother you that a lot of
californians are moving over there
you know what you would think i have a
problem with
being sunburned but i don't because i
know in a couple days i'm going to look
fantastic
you know what else i feel really good
about is the exercise that i'm getting
on this trip
because my whoop band is recording
data what's a woop band well it's this
strap i wear on my wrist
and it gathers more information about my
well-being my health my fitness my sleep
than any device known to man and i just
love wearing it you get the band
absolutely for free
when you sign up for the subscription
which comes with
this excellent app okay so i've told you
about it
and now i really want you to give it a
shot because it's going to make your
life better
like it makes my life better and so how
are we going to do that you're going to
go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
com use the promo code stevo for 15
off at checkout once again that's 15
off at checkout when you use the promo
code stevo
at woop.com and it's going to make your
life better i'm telling you
so let's find out if doc has a problem
with people going to texas
[ __ ] no it just means more money's
coming here
yeah so when when death row was
it was at its peak it's just going off
and like it's just
like everything's platinum like crazy
did you have like ownership in the
company like was it were you like
cut into yeah there was a time
early but it but but it wasn't at the
peak of different
it was in the beginning stages when
death row
was a company called future shock
and dray and i and suge
and another guy named dick griffey owned
this this company
and we signed all these young acts
and somewhere along the line
the name changed from future shock to
death row
and ariel had come around and by the
time that by the time
o started or or his energy
anyway by the time his energy started to
come around
i could feel myself kind of moving out
of the way
you know man and in that situation
you know what it's not a whole lot you
can [ __ ] do
in the state i was in at that time right
man like
any movement around number one it was
probably not the safest thing to be
doing to barking too loud
but if i start working they might take
away my candy then i'm all messed up
right so yeah i mean that's a time where
where people getting held over the
balcony you know like to sign over their
music
allegedly [ __ ] [ __ ] didn't have
anything to do with with uh
producing vanilla ice yes sign your [ __ ]
over to me that's [ __ ] great
and then uh so dream this sounds like
you didn't have to really like
you know cut ties too much like they
kind of had
had moved on before it all fell apart oh
yeah
dre had to just say all right hey man
for my safety i'm just going to walk
away i'm not bringing anything with me
and snoop got off like
in a much better situation because he
had master p come out
and buy out his contract yeah man yeah
man
it was great but it was great for snoop
to get out there in the world and do his
you know do it for himself yeah oh man
you know i mean start charting his own
course and i say this as like a big
brother
because you know like i raised snoop in
this game and
i love him a lot you know i mean i
wanted to win
so i would i wasn't there but i was
happy to see him
starting to pick those pieces up and
when he left
i knew it wouldn't be long before dre
left
and once dre left it it was you know
you know that was it that was a wrap so
when
when dre leaves he starts aftermath
and uh and you're you're [ __ ] with
dre the whole time right like
so you're you're behind the scenes like
what were you doing for for aftermath
when it
started off dre called me and asked me
to come help and put together an album
doing the same thing that i that i've
always done
you know a bit second set of ears some
ideas
right right right you know be the guy
next to the guy and so went back out
there
but by the andre had stacked he had just
found eminem
then he says to me i got somebody i want
you to listen to
right and he plays me this song called
i just don't give a [ __ ]
and i was like holy [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is
[ __ ] sick genius who is he dresses
hold on let me show you a picture
he showed me a picture of this little
short blonde white kid
and i was like get the [ __ ] out of here
hell yeah that's him he's like you think
i should [ __ ] with him
i was like what that [ __ ]
and to this day and still one of the
best [ __ ]
ever that will ever breathe upon a
microphone
the guy's a sick genius yeah
man it's crazy how like all the
relationships
you're saying i i i love love snoop you
know
like and then snoop's got like this
weird thing going back and forth with
him and you know like all the different
like relationships between people what's
that what's your relationship with snoop
like now so i'm like switzerland yeah i
mean
neutral i don't got no problems with
nobody
you know i mean like i don't ask
[ __ ] for [ __ ]
why do i do something but usually it's
never
and uh you know i'm like big uncle you
know man like i only bring love
i don't bring drama and i try to work
for you to help you be better and grow
as a [ __ ] man
inside this show business [ __ ] cause
that's just not easy
yeah i mean go back to their
those guys going back and forth that's
all show business [ __ ] yeah man like
you gotta spin in this game together for
[ __ ] eons you
sit down and talk to one another
whatever whatever but
you know one person gets all of it
that's on the news yeah
blah blah blah something and you got to
do that
i said suck my dick but nobody like that
you know me cuz i don't bring no trouble
yeah i don't think there's anything too
serious about that
about that situation anyways man but
dude so now
like now you got a [ __ ]
big time acting [ __ ] going on
i mean but this this is crazy man i
heard this
and i was like wow like you got a movie
coming out with bruce willis
why did that like yo i mean
it's the coolest [ __ ] [ __ ] that
ever happened bro to be honest with you
i'm acting with bruce willis and i'm die
hard
i mean it's just the greatest [ __ ] ever
so
yeah bro like you know how there's a
point you you
you live the life so you know there's a
point that you get to it
where [ __ ] clicks again and it starts
going back
up you know man that's where i'm at
right now i can see [ __ ]
really clearly right now i'm still
not quite all the way to myself yet but
i feel real strong and [ __ ]
and all these opportunities are [ __ ]
just happening so
i'm super blessed right now man struggle
with
learning to play my base help me
understand
what what do you mean i'm still not
quite myself right now
i haven't found my thing to bust my nut
yet it might be acting
all right and [ __ ] looked at me
like
i didn't know that i looked at them like
i didn't know either but
but they thought i was good so so we'll
see maybe that's
the thing i'm starting to get more
comfortable with this voice [ __ ]
maybe i can make this [ __ ] work yeah man
like it's distinctive as [ __ ]
oh man dude i'm so glad you said that
because
like with my voice i've been and
if i'm honest still like self-conscious
about it man sometimes like
sometimes uh i really like stress about
it like man it's getting worse or
it's you know or like [ __ ] and and and
the best thing i could do
for myself was to speak up about my
insecurity
you know like speak up about it and hear
people tell me man
[ __ ] are you kidding me dude that
[ __ ] is you man that's
trademark you know like a lot of people
put kind of wind in my sails saying dude
i would own it you know that's who you
are
and uh still i wonder if i can like
i i got a voice coach and [ __ ] i got
this guy
[ __ ] making me like sing and be like
whoo
one two three four five oh
and you live the same life bro cuz i've
done that
oh [ __ ] i'm doing it and i gotta tell
you some different some crazy [ __ ]
so they might be trying to make me the
bionic
it's a decision i gotta make so i went
to
see this doctor uh stem cell guy
about 15 years ago and uh
went to see him because i missed you
know working
and uh the guy says man i'm sorry it's
really
you know it's just all [ __ ] up in this
nothing anybody can do
so the guy calls me about 10 months ago
says i've been thinking about you for
the past 15 years i think i've found
something that can help you
wow i know right when did this happen
when did he call
he called just as far was beginning to
hit
last year september october sometime
and uh we were in the middle of kovid i
had all these other things going on so i
haven't really
sat down and thought about it yet yeah i
mean but
but damn it 50 and 50 young man
baby [ __ ] rapper bro
you got a [ __ ]
you look great man the smile that's why
when you said i'm still not quite myself
i was trying to figure it out because i
feel like i'm looking at a guy who's
in a great place but look good [ __ ]
smiling and [ __ ] gotta [ __ ] with
what's the bruce willis movie coming out
on so it's uh
it's called gasoline alley and
i'd be lying to you if i told you
anything more than that
okay from me and said can you do it and
i said
[ __ ] yeah i can do it that's great man
give me a ticket you know it was great
yes that was my second movie
of the year i did a
musical of all [ __ ] things
they said do you think you could write a
song for this
i said [ __ ] yeah i can write a song for
that and record it
sure if that's what you want recorded
they were like
blown away by it they were like this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] amazing
would you be in the movie i was like
[ __ ] yeah i'll be in the movie
and then i flew to australia it was it
was some fantastic experience
there's no [ __ ] culvert there you
know man it was
it was a it was a [ __ ] trip being
there
didn't you have to like quarantine for
like two weeks
yeah that's probably pretty helpful yeah
man and uh
you did now speaking of of uh making
music i don't know if you were ever
aware but there was a brief minute there
where i was making a rap album myself
wow this one the whole idea started out
as like it was like funny it's like a
joke it was going to be a comedy
gangster rap album
okay the name of the album was
hard as a rock you know it's just like
and uh
was the first song poke the puss that
dad sucks like poke the puss
i had a song called down with stds
you know it started out like in a good
spirit and it was kind of funny but the
thing was that i was
out of control on drugs man i was like
uh you know
and i started seeing myself as like the
white odb
if i could just know like and i started
kind of taking it seriously in a way
that took the funny out of it you know
like uh everything got tangled up and
and um i was just too i was in too bad
of shape so i ended up going to rehab
and and that pro that whole project went
away and looking back on it if i'm
honest
it it was the most embarrassing chapter
in my life
you know i was like i was a douche with
a capital o dude
i gotta tell you i [ __ ] love the idea
i think we should revisit that that's
what i was gonna i was just getting
ready to say that you know like all
these years later
it it's on my mind to at least
at least make like one track like a
a rap redemption you know
hey we both got the perfect voices dude
great stories i mean dude i'm telling
you man i think like you and me and dude
when's the last time you recorded some
bars man
it's been a minute me too
but i write every day i'm still a writer
right that's my thing
yeah but but i haven't recorded anything
of
of consequences i mean dude if you were
going to record
a comeback track like
you and me dude that would be a pretty
big deal
yeah and i like it yeah i like it a lot
too
man anything that's on some positive
[ __ ] bro i'm with this [ __ ]
yeah for sure man and uh curious to know
like with with
with the the history with the substance
abuse like where are you at with that
now maybe we see
you you got your joint you're gonna are
you california sober
this is a uh cbd no
no thc there
that's great you're a shower not a
blower i'm a dad now
you know and i do smoke weed
all right all the other stuff i let that
go
father now i got two sons five
and seven and i'm just i
i realize i'm just really [ __ ]
blessed
to have gone through that [ __ ] and be
where i'm at right now
you know man so the rest of the way i
think i'm gonna post this [ __ ] i'm not
going
no turbulence the rest of this
[ __ ] way we gonna slide out
you know yeah dude that's epic man so
what what's going on with with dre you
and drake just
are always tight trey sends me a record
every almost every morning for the past
[ __ ] four months dress sent me a [ __ ]
new record
because you just [ __ ] make records
all the time and send them to me and say
what do you think and then i have to say
the motherfucker's the [ __ ] just like
the last one [ __ ]
just like the one before that
[ __ ] is great
that's awesome man i i remember i i met
dre
at it was like [ __ ] what like 2009
and uh i was just newly sober but i was
like
with some chick i was trying to like
chase some tail around so i ended up in
this bar
like what am i doing in a bar i'm a
sober guy with like you know but if i
bump into dre
the place was called hot and i was then
dream stoked said oh man i'm a fan of
jackass
and i told dre i said hey man i'm not
allowed to say this
but i can't not tell you but like dude
we just [ __ ]
locked in jackass 3d it's gonna happen
you know
and he was all like yeah yeah and then
you know and i wonder if you can help me
understand this because when i was
watching the
the the hbo series the defiant ones
it i remember hearing dre say
that he had the chronic and that he
brought the chronic
this epic album and he brought it to all
these record labels and everybody
[ __ ] rejected it right and so was
that why
he started aftermath was because he had
the chronic and nobody would buy it
i think we can all agree that you would
be out of your mind not to buy the
chronic
and if you're a guy like me i'd say
you're out of your mind
if you don't buy blue chew tablets why
because they make boning more fun
yeah i said it what are blue chew
tablets
well they're a chewable tablet that
happens to be delicious
and has the same active ingredient as
both
viagra and cialis and you know what
i said it'd be crazy not to buy them but
i'm going to give you a deal
where you don't even have to buy them
because you're going to get them
completely for free a whole month's
supply
and all you have to pay is just five
dollars for shipping
this is an unbelievable deal and
on top of that you don't have to have an
awkward
uncomfortable visit to the doctor
because when you go to bluechew.com
you just consult with one of their
medical providers
and that's how you sort out your
prescription and then
boom your tablets show up in the mail
it is that easy and i'm telling you
i have tried them with lux on multiple
occasions
and we had more fun than ever
so you have nothing to lose how are you
going to get this
deal you're going to go to bluechew.com
and you are going to use the promo code
stevo
and that is going to get you an entire
month's supply
of bluetooth tablets and all you have to
pay
is five dollars for shipping it's an
incredible deal
so right now head on over to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
stevo
and get ready to have the time of your
life boning away now
let's see what happened with the chronic
aftermath was
way after that aftermath is it's like 2
2001. after memphis 2000 you're talking
about the chronic is 19 and
94. oh damn okay
because dude i really latched on to this
man
because what i did i i got into stand-up
comedy right and i'm going around
doing stand-up comedy and like a lot of
people they're just all of stevo's doing
stand with comedy
they want to [ __ ] on that you know but
but i never i never let it stop me man i
just kept doing it i kept
i kept [ __ ] putting in the work
putting in the work and gradually as i
started doing it more and more i thought
you know what
what makes my comedy different is that
i'm telling stories that are [ __ ] 100
true and there's footage so i'm gonna
make my stand-up comedy special
like a funny act but i'm gonna take the
footage and i'm gonna edit it in
so that you can see what i'm telling
jokes about see the actual [ __ ] happen
and i [ __ ] tripped out man i thought
that was the greatest thing ever
so what i did was i funded my own
multimedia comedy special i made the
whole [ __ ] thing
and and i and i felt like damn this is
the chronic
this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] and i brought
it to all these people to netflix
everyone you know like
everybody could show it and they all
[ __ ] rejected it
they all rejected it and i took a
[ __ ] inspiration from dre
i was like dude i called it this [ __ ]
thing is the chronic
and i put it out on my own i [ __ ] i
put it out on my own and uh i did real
well with it man
i didn't do it so [ __ ] idea you can't
you can't [ __ ] on a great idea but as
you know
the business that we chose is full of
[ __ ]
sometimes yeah and so it's a lot of
a lot of assholery going on in
in this game so as long as you put as
long as you do to yourself
and what you do you really can't lose
yeah dude oh man i
love that and so how did the chronic end
up coming out
so we made the record
brain sugar was probably going around
everybody trying to get it
and uh that was probably still
paperwork issues with
ruthless i don't know if
if dre and i and michelle had gotten
released
yet that was a whole big deal and uh
i think by the time it made it to uh
ivan's desk he was able to cut through
all of that red tape
and put the record out lazy because ivan
was his a
as a producer like drake so he and dre
have a kindred kind of thing
but they understand but i knew that
dre's production
like it's all about dre's ear man that
[ __ ] is just [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
that person man but it's just
i mean wade turns those [ __ ] knives
it's crazy right and i don't think he
knew it before i can do it
but i knew that when jimmy heard that
[ __ ] he was like holy [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] i need
to be with this [ __ ] because
that's how i felt you know what i'm
saying yeah
and so after that that match was made in
heaven
both of those guys turned into
billionaires you know i mean
it's just that all the [ __ ] that
happened along the way
probably could have been avoided but
people got a plenty of roles man it's
just
it's the nature of the beast yeah man
did you watch straight out of compton
yeah would you think about that i think
the question is did you get paid for
straight out of content
no no no consulting no nothing huh
nah bro that wasn't my movie that was
their movie
yeah and i was there to support my guys
as much as i could because i know that
when it's time
i'm gonna get my movie all right you
know support me
dude that's that that's [ __ ] that's a
big deal man a lot of people
wouldn't see it that way a lot of people
would get a little
[ __ ] squirrely but they'd get
resentful you know man that's the
attitude to happen i respect that
hey i appreciate that bro let me tell
you something i learned a lot
from this journey and the number one
[ __ ] lesson i learned was [ __ ]
humility
because you don't have to even [ __ ]
be here
i could have been [ __ ] gone that
night on the [ __ ] 101 bro
yeah it's happened to plenty of other
[ __ ]
why not me you know i'm saying and so
when i look at them little boys
i just think to myself besides another i
just think to myself i'm not gonna let
the [ __ ] [ __ ] up
at all and i got a 16 year old daughter
there's a singer her name is erica baidu
i got a 16 year old daughter with erica
i do
and she sounds like an angel
when she sings and so i know
that i'm gonna go to many more concerts
as an old [ __ ] man
and maybe get some money this time
because my baby will give
that's great i bought erica badu's album
it's
phenomenal yeah
so uh so you're you're at your crib
in dallas right now yes is there a
studio in
in the crib no there's a uh
there's a base and a lead
and uh and that's it some lights for me
to do myself
all right so when we record our track
where are we going to record it
we're going to we're going to uh gary
o's building he's got the [ __ ] studio
all right that's good i'm jazz on man
i'm really
i'm not lazy you know i'm not lazy dude
i i i
you know [ __ ] around here
yeah dude [ __ ] i love it yeah dude
i love it a lot man so so we got more
uh like more acting she said the acting
might be it
right you got an agent booking the
acting [ __ ]
well i think uh i got an
agent you know i'ma do a little i'm
gonna do whatever comes my way
i mean i think i might wanna try to take
a class or something if i really wanna
be good at this [ __ ]
uh-huh learn some [ __ ] about it you know
i mean
um but yeah bro i'm just taking it one
by one by one
whatever comes handling handle it the
right way
take the bit cause i'm super blessed
right now bro if i told you
all the [ __ ] that's on my plate right
now would [ __ ] shouldn't be out
well dude i mean if uh if you're allowed
to say it man tell me about some of that
i can't do
[Applause]
but it feel some of it when i told you
about the doctor
right okay yeah oh man that sounds like
it could be a [ __ ] pretty bitchin ass
documentary
anything is possible bro but the bionic
rapper with the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] stem cells to [ __ ] bring
the doc
back [ __ ] into the [ __ ] booth
but we're gonna get in the booth and
we're gonna dude i love it man i love it
let me tell you this too
i don't know if what you're talking
about with that doctor is stem cell
related
but i got a [ __ ] this guy he hit me
up he's a legend
of the [ __ ] guinness book of world
records he's the skateboarder that
jumped the
skateboard the highest ever out of
anybody on earth
and and he's a legend named danny way
and we're the same age me and danny way
so we're getting up there right
47 years old almost and uh danny's got
no
[ __ ] like cartilage left in his knees
he he wants to keep jumping his
skateboard man but his [ __ ]
so so danny found out about stem cell
[ __ ]
where like it's not even legal in
america
or in europe so we're we're we're flying
to [ __ ] columbia
to go set a new world record for getting
pumped for the most
stem cells that any human beings haven't
been [ __ ] danny's gonna do that i'm
gonna get pumped up pretty good but
danny's gonna really get pumped up
these stems in america the only stem
cell [ __ ] that's legal is if they
pull it out of your your bone marrow
yeah or some liposuction [ __ ] but it's
gotta come out of your own body
and when they do that the injections
don't even have like a million stem
cells
but what we're doing we're going to
colombia where they take
like a placenta not a positive umbilical
cord
umbilical cord the umbilical cord for a
newborn baby
so like here in america the stem cells
are as old as you are you got old ass
[ __ ] yeah
but yeah you got like this out of the
umbilical cord it's like
the the stem cells are zero years old
and there's [ __ ]
tens of millions of them like i don't
know why but yes we're gonna go do and
check it out
like if you want to [ __ ] uh any info
on this and dude that's the other thing
too they're letting me do it for free i
just gotta like
tell the world i'm doing it and i cannot
like
i can't wait to tell it i'm telling you
i'm trying to tell everybody i love it
yeah i can connect you with the people
if you're interested
too if stem cells are just gonna it's
gonna get you [ __ ]
where you want with the bionic rapper
then maybe colombia is the ticket dude
i'll give you all the info man
say something to think about bro
something to think about
really no i'm serious i'm really
seriously
giving a thought but i don't want to put
anything in front of my family right no
of course man my focus is right right
now yeah
i don't want to be 52 years old trying
to jack off
we got [ __ ] to do stevo that's right man
i do i love it yeah are you gonna write
your own uh song are you gonna get a
ghost writer
is he gonna help you right i mean dude
let me ask you this
doc when did ghost riding become such a
[ __ ] crime man i mean
like right like i mean you were writing
[ __ ] for everybody
right he wrote the whole [ __ ]
straight out of compton [ __ ]
right i wrote my parts but i mean i know
cube wrote a lot
but uh the the writing was done by me
ice cube and m.c wren right get off the
lighting
we shared the jobs and you got credit
for writing too
and you got credit for being a writer i
didn't get
[Laughter]
you're opening up these wounds bro i i'm
not even trying to
i i i've always understood that to be
the case so i think on stage
it's understood on it's understood
yeah it's from the street level and from
everyone
if my dumb ass understands that i think
you got credit so i think we're good
then saying on the paperwork is what i'm
saying yeah man
to the publishing
[Laughter]
yeah the worst part about like getting
successful is that like you start
getting contracts and you have to get
lawyers and so then you get a lawyer
and then the lawyer that you get sends
you a contract you're like [ __ ] i need a
lawyer
to read what the lawyer just sent me i i
i don't know how you guys do it i i
don't know either
i don't know either dude but uh but but
we'll do it
man it's crazy too like that there's
real money
like uh you see these [ __ ] youtube
[ __ ] they just [ __ ] make
make a song and then that song is
platinum and [ __ ] like dude the money's
there
that's the age we in bro all you need is
one viral thing
and you're just on this road for a
minute you know i mean right
that's where we're at you know i mean
that's why you and i can make a record
and be on tour for seven months with
[ __ ] one record
dude i'm telling you man like if if you
and i made a record
like that the connection that we have
with our voices
the [ __ ] like you being the [ __ ]
i mean i mean dude like a legend of
hip-hop that doesn't even do
that's not even enough to say [ __ ]
what you are
you know like we would we would have to
be a guinness
for the most raggedy [ __ ] voice
dude i love it man i love it dude well
i'll i'll tell you what man let's follow
up on that dude
like i'll [ __ ] uh on the other side
of this man i'll give you i'll give you
my number
[ __ ] i say let's do it dude i'm all
around
hey what can we promote for you we got
the
the bruce willis movie are we ready to
point people
to where it is yeah uh you know what i'm
like
you know my guy gary oh yeah
he's that guy has really been busting
his ass
for some reason to try to get me
hey baby to try to get me
working moving building growing and
and so how that got a lot i wanted to
say his name on here if anybody knows
[ __ ] with gary yo he's good he's a good
guy all right
yeah just [ __ ] just get it through carry
on let's just use him to keep the
connection
and how do they find gary o yeah how how
do people find gary oh
i don't know
if you can't figure out how to [ __ ]
fight gary or maybe you don't need to be
[ __ ] wasting his time
i i tell people [ __ ] like that you're
like oh man like i say man i'm an easy
guy to get a hold of dude if
you're a pro you [ __ ] get me real
easy
if you're not a pro then you don't need
to know
all right man well hey dude we'll let
you get back to your to your base and
your family and
i just wanted to tell you what an honor
this was man really thank you
god bless you steve old man i'm i'm i'm
a huge fan
and i rock with you it's nice to meet
you guys nice to meet you too doc
yeah dude information and i know i'm
gonna see you later my friend
can we get a beat real quick on the bass
is that incredible or what i just
basically became
bros with a legend and i don't think
that he would mind
me telling you that we have connected on
text
and actually texted about recording my
rap
redemption track i mean dude that's just
straight up
a big deal and uh okay
last week for those of you who stick
around at the very end
i did talk about getting into vlogging i
might have mentioned
something crazy like on a daily basis
and i totally decided against that but
vlogging all the way okay my next main
channel video i'm gonna give away
more like [ __ ] that i shouldn't give
away
right i'm gonna be out of my mind like
you know what hey have a look at this
have a look at this have a look at this
because i'm so excited that it's all
going on
and uh the big announcement the reason
why i'm giving away so much is because
there is a new vlog channel and i can't
even wait
to just welcome you guys uncomfortably
for me and lux
into our very private and personal lives
so yeah dudes there's a lot going on i'm
really excited
i love you thank you